hey guys it's Alicia Malloy Fandango
movie clips I'm here at comer phone on
the press line for Lionsgate let's go to
the stars
maybe no the Stasi from the Kansai file
that's the energy like inside the panel
it intends it's so exciting
you know normally are doing interviews
for a bunch of reporters that don't
actually care they're just kind of
recording for the people who do care so
now we're in a room with the people who
you know the biggest fans so it's just
it's exciting when you look back on the
whole series what are you most proud of
I mean I'm very proud to be in a movie
that has such a great message that's
being so you know that's so huge that
has such a giant fan base and that we
really are doing what I think is the
right thing will you miss hanging out
with the cast we all hang out you know
we're all best friends so we still hang
out but I'll definitely miss you know
I'm going to work with them it's it's
it's a much different energy you know
when you
will you miss coming to comic-con with
hunger games specifically because a fan
of course you think that our fans are
all really cool geeky smart intelligent
young people who really understand like
the sophisticated story of these films
they're looking back with the series as
a whole when we sum up the legacy 500
the game I think was really great about
what a different film industries is it
took me on a young adult novel and and
really found one that has great messages
and found one that has really driven
political themes and things like that
and and populate it with really talented
people directors actors you know
departments everything can we find
coverage keep searching Fandango movie
clips